malgré sa réussite économique indéniable
50 ans en Yvelines est un territoire
vaste sur lequel on puisse installer des
disparités suite à la construction
rapide de certains quartiers dans les
années 60 c'est pas une politique
volontaire de solidarité que la
communauté d'agglomération les communes
et leur partenaire luttent contre ces
inégalités comme nous allons le voir
tout de suite c'est par là
non non par là c'est par là
à 50 ans en Yvelines la solidarité
depuis 40 ans au coeur de l'action
publique de nombreux dispositifs
traduisent cet engagement et permet
d'agir au quotidien dans le cadre de la
politique de la ville par exemple la
communauté d'agglomération a signé un
contrat urbain de cohésion sociale avec
l'État le Contrat Urbain cohésion
sociale c'est un contrat qui va lier la
collectivité donc la communauté
d'agglomération mais également 5
communes de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
avec l'État et l'ensemble de ses
partenaires décident de mobiliser des
moyens spécifiques pour conduire des
actions politiques de la ville dans les
quartiers qui sont les plus en
difficulté là où se cumulent le plus de
difficultés socio-économiques
l'objectif il est d'apporter des
services spécifiques dans ces quartiers
propres pour apporter des réponses
nouvelles en fait pour pour les
habitants alors quelques exemples
attrapent par exemple mais également
dans d'autres communes de la Communauté
d'Agglomération à La Verrière au Mali en
a le point service aux particuliers qui
permet de d'apporter des réponses de
résoudre des litiges entre les habitants
et dans certains cas les services
publics donc il s'agit d'apporter avec
les services publics des réponses à ces
différents litiges autre exemple la
maison de justice et du droit qui permet
d'apporter un accueil un conseil
juridique pour accompagner les
populations les habitants qui sont
confrontés à différents types de
difficultés soit dans le domaine du
droit du travail dans le domaine du
droit de la famille ou de la
consommation pour régler ses difficultés
donc on a également la santé publique
donc là je pense notamment à l'Institut
de promotion de la santé et puis de lieu
et coup de jeunes qui permettent
d'accueillir des jeunes qui ont besoin
d'une d'un accompagnement psychologique
de cours ou de moyen terme on a l'emploi
bien sûr le développement économique qui
sont qui sont concernés et le logement
et l'habitat bien évidemment avec la
mise en œuvre du plan local pour
l'habitat
pour garantir un niveau de mixité
sociale au sein de l'agglomération le
programme local de l'habitat voté en
2013 prévoit au cours des prochaines
années la construction de 1300 logements
par an afin de rééquilibrer l'offre en
proposant aux habitants des logements
adaptés à leurs besoins et à leurs
moyens concernant l'emploi il y a bien
sûr la Maison de l'Emploi et de la
Formation le plan local pour l'insertion
et l'emploi ou encore la Cité des
métiers mais avant l'emploi il y a aussi
la scolarité
c'est une école qui accueille des jeunes
qui entre 18 et 25 ans qui sont sortis
du système éducatif depuis au moins un
an qui ont envie de s'insérer à la fois
socialement et professionnellement
et il y a juste une petite contrainte
pour pouvoir rentrer à l'école de la
deuxième chance c'est qu'il faut être
sans diplôme ni qualification en fait
nous on a des critères de recrutement à
l'inverse des autres écoles il y a un
partenariat très très étroit avec la
communauté d'agglo puisque la communauté
d'agglo fait partie des membres
fondateurs l'école c'est aussi une
association le 1901 et dans les
fondateurs de cette association de
l'Ouest 901 il y a la communauté
d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui est un
partenaire historique de l'école qui a
voulu cette école et qui le prouve tous
les ans en participant au financement
cette école pour les jeunes c'est un
véritable acte de courage en moyenne ils
ont 20 ans ils ont entre 18 et 24 mais
en moyenne ils ont 20 ans c'est vrai que
de s'inscrire de sa propre initiative à
une école qui s'appelle école de la
deuxième chance c'est une vraie décision
et de surcroît c'est une vraie décision
parce que on leur demande beaucoup c'est
une école où il travaille beaucoup et
puisqu'il les étonne le plus c'est
qu'ils finissent par y prendre goût
on va travailler sur deux plans
principaux le premier plan et ben c'est
ce qu'on appelle en gros les compétences
de base c'est à dire avoir les
connaissances suffisantes pour lire et
écrire compter utiliser les outils
informatiques savoir être à la fois un
travailleur mais aussi un citoyen à part
entière et avoir les moyens de vivre
dans la société et ça c'est plutôt notre
côté insertion sociale et c'est la
moitié du temps et l'autre moitié du
temps en fait les élèves sont les
stagiaires de notre école sont en stage
dans les entreprises où ils vont pouvoir
découvrir des métiers les essayer voir
ce pour lesquelles ils ont des affinités
des compétences aussi et puis construire
petit à petit à la fois les premières
compétences et acquérir les premiers
gestes techniques et puis aussi
constituer un réseau de connaissances
professionnelles se faire connaître et
reconnaître des employeurs de la région
et puis au fil de ces stages au bout
d'un moment ce professionnels se dessine
ils deviennent crédible sur ce projet
ils deviennent aussi crédible à leur
propre yeux on a beaucoup de métiers qui
vont vers le commerce la distribution
l'aide à la personne puis après des
métiers un peu plus industriels ou
techniques comme la mécanique travaux
publics le second œuvre principalement
les métiers de bouche une centaine de
jeunes sont ainsi accueillis chaque
année des élèves qui font leur rentrée
par petits groupes tous les mois ils
peuvent s'inscrire à l'école de la
deuxième chance tout au long de l'année
et on accueille environ une dizaine de
jeunes tous les mois on oscille entre un
taux de sortie positive qui varie entre
60 et 70% de sortie positives sur les
jeunes qui ont validé la période d'essai
donc c'est une situation c'est une
formation qui qui fonctionne les jeunes
qui s'y mettent ils arrivent à trouver
des débouchés autre priorité pour la
casse qui réduire les inégalités sur le
marché du travail ou dans la vie
quotidienne depuis 2005 avec l'aide de
nombreux partenaires comme le club face
ou le pli elle a mis en place
deux plans de lutte contre les
discriminations c'est dans ce cadre
qu'au mois de décembre les comédiens de
déclices théâtre compagnie partenaire
depuis le début iront alors rencontre
des élèves du territoire on nous a
proposé de réaliser des outils de
sensibilisation sur le thème des
discriminations
dans un premier temps on était orienté
sur le monde de l'entreprise donc on a
fait la tête de l'emploi qui a tourné
dans des dans des entreprises dans des
clubs d'entreprises des choses comme ça
et en fait à chaque étape de travail on
est vraiment en collaboration avec une
avec une structure de la casquine qui
est aidée par la casquette dans ce dans
ce cadre-là on a beaucoup travaillé avec
le club face pour écrire la tête de
l'emploi et là pour le Welcome à bord
qui est donc le spectacle à destination
des collèges on a travaillé avec le
lycée Mathis et donc notre travail en
gros c'est de s'immerger le plus
possible dans les problématiques réelles
du terrain du concret et puis de faire
émerger des personnages des situations
et donc un spectacle en décembre deux
spectacles d'improvisation sont aussi
prévus en primaire et ils seront donc
suivis de à partir du 9 10 et 11
décembre en collège welcome à bord qui a
un spectacle là pour le coin spectacle
écrit et à la fin de chaque spectacle on
a un débat qui est en général organisé
par la Maison de la justice et du droit
et on se rend compte que oui vous allez
touche énormément c'est c'est dingue ça
ça parle de stéréotype ça parle d'avenir
de qu'est-ce que je deviens si je suis
une fille si je suis un garçon si je
suis blanc si je suis noir si je suis
petit si je suis grand dans les débats
qui sont après les spectacles que c'est
même brûlant c'est même la question par
exemple la question de la femme c'est
quelque chose qui est qui est censé quoi
c'est à dire qu'on a des donc oui il
faut dire ça à des collégiennes parce
que c'est les collégiennes qui sont les
qui sont les femmes de demain et c'est
elle qu'il faut bien tu es pas obligé de
de te marier de pas travailler et de
d'attendre que ton mari fasse tout dans
ta vie
et voilà et voilà pour la solidarité et
maintenant on voit les actus du moi
c'est par là
c'est bientôt Noël et vous manquez
d'idées alors ce qui va suivre vous
intéresse depuis le 1er décembre un
nouvel ouvrage sur l'agglomération est
disponible ce livre et la rencontre de
deux univers les photographies de
Francis tac et les poésies de Paul Jean
mervion il est disponible à l'Office de
Tourisme ou en librairie
le Conseil général des Yvelines Yvelines
tourisme et la société smart and Co
lance le coffret y box qui permet de
profiter de plus de 80 offres de loisirs
à demi-tarifs durant un an pour
découvrir le département sous
différentes facettes loisirs tourisme
cultura et détente c'est à consommer
sans modération et ses disponible à
l'Office de Tourisme Noël toujours et le
reste à l'Office de Tourisme qui vous
propose une fois encore son expo de Noël
pour toute la famille elle est conçue
d'ailleurs cette année autour des contes
petits aigands seront ravis et
franchement nous on a vraiment aimé
voilà pour descendre et en attendant
éliminant ouverture au public du
Vélodrome de 50 ans en Yvelines début
2014 la casquette vous propose de gagner
des places pour la soirée d'inauguration
qui aura lieu en janvier vous pouvez
jouer du 6 au 18 décembre et c'est sur
le 3W
un dossier que vous pouvez retrouver
dans le petit Quentin du mois de
décembre ainsi qu'un article sur les
formations au développement durable et
sur un atelier santé de l'habitat et
qualité de l'air intérieur proposé par
l'Institut de promotion de la santé de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines à très bientôt